tras las fiestas decembrinas en mexico
en la epidemia de kobe 19 ha vuelto a
niveles de alerta y es que se ha
superado ya la barrera de los 300.000
muertos por coronavirus oficialmente
reconocidos esto es 5 veces el escenario
catastrófico que se había previsto al
inicio de la pandemia en un país donde
la letalidad es de las más altas por
cada 100 casos confirmados de hecho es
la más alta entre los 20 países más
afectados de acuerdo con la universidad
johns hopkins en cuanto a contagios
hemos vuelto a niveles no vistos en
meses el pico máximo de contagios para
un solo día ocurrió el 18 de agosto y
esta semana hemos vuelto a niveles
arriba de los 28 mil casos en 24 horas a
pesar de ello no hay una saturación
hospitalaria la ocupación en camas de
hospitalización general es de 19% lo que
sí luce abarrotado es los quioscos los
módulos de pruebas gratuitas de
detección de kobe son largas filas desde
temprana hora
antes del mediodía las pruebas ya se han
agotado en todo el país el semáforo
epidémico estaba en verde y hay algunos
estados que comienzan ya a retroceder al
amarillo es el caso de quintana roo
donde se ubica el famoso destino
turístico de cancún en la ciudad de
mexico se ha decidido continuar una
semana más en el semáforo verde sin
embargo hay afectaciones en otros
aspectos por ejemplo se han cancelado
decenas de vuelos debido a los contagios
entre la tripulación de las aerolíneas